man who gives out my phone number to Tom
Izzo without asking Mary you don't worry
mooch you know I was surprised he didn't
have your number because he's been on
your show as me he has been on your show
already and so I thought you guys are
buddies just out of the blue he calls
you he wants to bust my must burglars
about you got to give me aizen's number
I got to just get him I just got to get
him right now I said you sure you gonna
do this yeah I can again and so you know
the rest is history gotcha he did but
you know you know you you can get them
back rich you know paybacks always you
know what it is Michigan State I will
give you his number in football right
but in hoops though that's that that'll
be wrong right FFF 15 line catches is oh
that's too close to home isn't it that
cuts too close to the bone Steve right
no do it so let's talk about what what
is Mike McCarthy thinking right now
Steve oh my god that's what he's
thinking
you know rich I went through the same
thing not not that I'm insensitive but I
you know I was at the Niners when Steve
Young maybe more serious because he got
the concussion at Arizona on Monday
Night Football and we didn't know it at
the time but essentially his career was
over Aaron Rodgers will come back at
some point Steve Young was was done and
so you have to move on mentally and and
and find the guy who who can do it I'm
hoping that Brett Hundley has been there
long enough to know and understand this
system and rhythm up with these
receivers so they don't drop off too far
but you know I heard you say work Tony
Romo yeah he's a he's a cheese head he's
at Wisconsin I mean yes it farms he had
farms poster on the wall and look I said
this last time that's kind of a juicy
rumor and everything but Tony's doing
yeah I think Tony's doing great in the
booth he is I love listening to the guy
but but that's neither here nor there
Steve you know well as anybody are the
guy who sits two seats to the left of
you on gameday morning
Warner got calls when he said I'm
definitely done Peyton Manning got calls
after he said I'm definitely done Romo
said I'm definitely done and Cutler got
a phone call so what don't you think
we're all those phone rings from the
Packers today Steve I don't know I don't
know if I don't know you know it's a
different system he would Tony would be
terrific there but I don't think he'd
move I don't think he'd do it I think
he's just comfortable now and in like in
his new career and I think Mike McCarthy
will be confident enough and Hundley did
say we can win enough games and win this
division but it would be awesome
wouldn't it the fans would be crazy
about Tony Romo I know that well we had
a couple already say that they don't
want him that they think he's been on
his behind a little bit too long and for
them the you know obviously this week
for against the Saints wouldn't be the
time but there's a bye week although
that would be I guess the week to maybe
coach Hundley up as well that's at least
right around the corner Steve
right I mean it yeah or do you think Ted
Thompson and and and McCarthy are really
putting their heads together and having
this conversation today do you think
no I yeah of course they're talking
about it but I I just think they're
gonna settle in and then figure out what
honey can do well and keep it I don't
want to say keep it simple but keep it
the volume of offense such that he's
good with it all he's practiced it
against different coverages and
different fronts and he's he understands
the game plan well and they and they win
as many games with him as they can I'm
about 93 percent certain that's the
direction they're going Steve Mariucci
my compadre from NFL gameday morning
getting set for Thursday Night Football
in his backyard Chiefs and Raiders
kicking off week seven on Thursday night
right here on the Rich Eisen show what
did the Steelers do to the Chiefs that
no one else has been able to do to the
Chiefs Steve and like two years have
their number rich I mean we talked about
it on the show a you know Ben is now
seven and one against the Chiefs and we
talked about you know he beat him twice
last year once in the playoffs but the
other game regular season last year Big
Ben threw five touchdowns and no picks I
mean they just they're a good team that
the Steelers are a good team and they
kind of went through a theory
there for a couple of weeks where
Antonio Brown is throwing Gatorade
bottles and then Ben throws five pics
and loses and sounds like he's tapping
out and lo and behold the Steelers are
for real
and now martavis Bryant wants to be
traded because he's not getting enough
falls over there but they're a good team
and they're gonna meet again in the
playoffs they're you know I they met
last year and it was a 18 to 16 playoff
game and it's gonna be like that again
right but do they is it just as simple
as saying they have a number or do you I
mean because they bottle up Kareem hunt
in a way that nobody else has been able
to they they they discombobulated the
team to the point where Andy is you know
has been pushing every button properly
but he went for it on fourth and goal
from the two instead of kicking a field
goal that I think he's probably kicking
himself about right now yeah and that
was close to you know he have used
instant replay to figure that one out
and yeah you know Pittsburgh's defense
it's got good team speed over there they
match up pretty pretty well if you can
stop it never thought I'd say this if
you can stop kareem hunt you can you can
beat them but they make it tougher Alex
Smith they do enough in the run game the
Steelers do they control the ball that's
what they did they had it for over 36
minutes they kept Alex Smith off the
field and all of his fast little weapons
off the field and in lady on bail just
went off yet on 179 yards rushing maybe
maybe that's the recipe to beat the
Chiefs but not many people can do that
because you don't have a lady on bail
that's true Steve Mariucci here in the
Rich Eisen show what's wrong with the
Raiders what happened to them four in a
row
I can't wait to go see what's going on
in person on Thursday Night Football but
now they have four losses in a row and
this was a this was a team that was some
of us when we made our predictions for
possible Super Bowl that you know the
Raiders were a consideration obviously
losing Derek Carr hurt them just for a
bit there but now he's back he looked a
little I think they protected him a
little bit and he was a little careful
but he's he's going to be fine they
didn't spend a lot of money on d4 when
you pay your quarterback okay and a lot
of teams have gone through this
Seattle or Baltimore with Flacco or you
know some of these contracts with these
hundred million dollar quarterbacks you
have to go without in certain areas of
your team and and I don't know if the
Raiders have spent enough money on
defense yet and Reggie McKinsey will
well you know continue to sort that out
in the offseason you know they've got
their they've got a lot of weapons on
offense great offensive line and they
have skilled guys that are getting paid
but on defense they need to keep
improving that defense for Kenny Norton
it's not good enough yet and and so
you're counting on a derrick karr to be
spectacular every week and it's it's
it's not happening to consistently this
this game against the Chiefs is huge for
both organizations what a game we have
on Thursday that is gonna be big and no
doubt about it
Steve it's the the third of the season
core post basically third of the season
stud I'll give you a mulligan or a
choice for Super Bowl 50 - what do you
have right now oh you know the Eagles
really impressed me the other night in
terms of the NFC because other teams in
the NFC Dallas is wounded Green Bay is
wounded the the Panthers are up-and-down
the Falcons look vulnerable at times I
think the Seahawks are okay at times but
the Eagles look like the most complete
team today all right
the Rams are the surprise team but I
think maybe a little too young so maybe
it's the Eagles right now at the quarter
Pole
the third poll those Steelers that we
saw are a contender in the AFC the
Chiefs are still a contender
the Patriots don't ever count them out
until Tom you know you know rides off
into the sunset
the Broncos looked I was shocked I was
shocked me too I think the whole
football world was shocked to see the
Giants actually just blow out the Denver
Broncos in my eyes well I was crazy and
before I try to pin you down on the AFC
team I mean Ben McAdoo coughing up the
play calling how difficult do you think
that was for him you know yeah IIIi did
that too and and you went out there when
did you do that
what would this
well I called the place when I first
went to the San Francisco 49ers and then
I eventually gave it up the second year
and then I say same thing with the
Detroit Lions if you can meet so some
coaches prefer Mike Holmgren call the
plays all the way through so de groots
some coaches prefer to do that some
coaches prefer to say hey I want to give
this responsibility to someone else
that's like-minded all right and he's
gonna call plays a little bit like I
will and I have veto power and and I
preferred that so I could go screaming
at officials and throwing angry flags
and keep it up with the injuries and the
defense and the challenges and the
timeouts and so I prefer to manage the
game but you have to find that guy who
is so who won't surprise you and run a
double reverse on 4th and 17 yeah I mean
you got to have a guy Mike Sullivan
seems to be that guy and in in Ben I
think it was a good time to do that
because they are having issues over
there
and you know what Mike Sullivan
delivered now Denver had more yards and
all of that but you know it looked it
looked like he had a little rhythm with
Eli
Colin plays it was I hope he keeps it
like that so Ben can just focus on
managing this football team and let Mike
Sullivan do that job he looks like he's
very capable so if we hit the time
machine you say it's Eagles versus
Superbowl 50 - right now Steve you're
gonna make me pick one huh yes sir
well earlier in the season I picked
Patriots and Packers and so I haven't
changed my mind Gronk's back he looked
great and then later on after the game
last night he was on shark tank did you
watch that no I missed that one research
all the Gronk showed up on shark tank I
couldn't leave it anyway if if Gronk
stays healthy I think maybe the Patriots
find their way back there muchas the
Eagles it happened before remember and
Ygritte I do remember that I do remember
that no question about I was in
Jacksonville Florida I was there just
you you were you were one year away from
joining the NFL Network you know what I
know it I was up I was up watching the
game with Don Shula and his wife are you
saying I was spectacular yeah yeah
you may get a Don Shula you think he's
happy you think he's happy and if no one
defeated teams rich that's every year
they pop champagne cork I thought you'd
say speaking of Don Shula that you had a
40 ounce steak for dinner last night I
thought that's a reading on 90 according
to that thing that is really last night
how come how come they make fun of you
with that that hotcakes thing you look
stupid on game day morning what we do on
game day morning we had that's cool Todd
yeah some guy came in and made pancakes
and our likeness isn't well I think they
handed out hot takes and then the the
way that we opened the show we showed
even being honored and the Ring of Honor
in Miami by the way on Saturday with a
big comeback win on Georgia Tech with
Warren Sapp and Ray Lewis and the family
of Sean Taylor and then we showed
Marshall Faulk honored at San Diego
State for getting in the College
Football Hall of Fame and then we showed
a shot of mooch in front of an empty
plate for the meat masters clean plate
you know any normal guy would take sense
that you know you're not alone guys take
care of mooch we'll see you Thursday
night I take my recharge the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show